ce n'est pas encore les niveaux du
tourisme d'avant covid mais ça s'y
rapproche entre janvier et juin dernier
l'Île-de-France a accueilli 21,5
millions de visiteurs une augmentation
de 17% par rapport au premier semestre
2022 la dynamique est confirmée par les
unités hôtelières également en forte
progression au total les touristes ont
généré 9,5 milliards d'euros de
retombées économiques pour la région
c'est une clientèle qualitative c'est
une clientèle qui consomme c'est une
clientèle
j'allais dire voilà celle que nous
voulons c'est à dire de du tourisme du
tourisme qui n'est pas du surtourisme
qui n'est pas du tourisme low cost qui
n'est pas du tourisme chip qui qui
serait qui risquerait d'abîmer nos sites
ou qui risquerait de déplaire j'allais
dire aux habitants et de les gêner la
clientèle internationale revient aussi
en nombre en Île-de-France cet été à la
représenté plus de la moitié des
touristes accueillis dans la région une
saison estivale qui a été également
positive malgré une météo parfois morose
il a pas fait si mauvais que ça en île
en France je dirais pas qu'il y a un
micro climat mais non on a eu quand même
des semaines de beau temps et puis on a
eu des semaines de temps qui sont tout à
fait convenables quand on vient visiter
une ville parce qu'en réalité quand on
vient visiter une ville on veut surtout
voir des monuments etc donc un temps un
temps de printemps n'est pas forcément
au contraire
dissuasif pour un tourisme
urbain c'est plus dissuasif évidemment
pour un tourisme balnéaire ou de
montagne et des perspectives sont bonnes
pour les prochains mois en vue de la
Coupe du monde de rugby qui se tient en
France la région s’attend à recevoir 450
000 supporters étrangers en majorité il
viendront de la Grande-Bretagne de
l'Argentine ou encore de la
Nouvelle-Zélande